welcome back to the Ingram angle now
more of my exclusive interview with the
president's attorney Rudy Giuliani even
buried in the New York Times a big New
York Times piece today is a little
nugget that you have to kind of search
for Rudy that says nothing publicly
disclosed ties the Trump campaign of the
President himself to these nefarious
dealings with the Russians that's again
you have to kind of look past the
headline all the way to that that's true
from day one it's true today they're not
gonna be able to invent any evidence of
that and it's a shame that they have
plus they won't answer Congress on how
much money this has caused any American
people of course that's a fortune these
guys you know figure they can't get a
good job you get the sense that they are
going to focus in on some type of
obstruction claim and I want to
recommend impeachment it I mean they
don't get to do that I mean they they
get to send a report to Rosenstein on
what they found I guess they could
virtuously include a recommendation but
really they shouldn't or the facts that
would indicate memo of him that were
bunched them all a thousand percent well
and it would be probably either about
the Trump Tower meeting there's still
confusion there a lot of wasn't
president right but he wasn't present at
but then Don trums you knew the
transcript notes of his talk with
Capitol Hill came out today Senate
committee released the notes and he said
he did not have a memory about talking
to his father with it specifically then
they're focusing on this blocked call
that he made that day and he doesn't
remember for was to his father or not I
mean that's the theory that they're
spinning out and since you since I
believe it took place in the office he
would have been very easy for him the
June of 2016
yeah also remember June of 2016 that's
about when I joined the campaign
nobody's gonna focus on a Russian woman
who says that she has false information
about Hillary turns out she wants to
negotiate sanctions and they throw her
out basically and then when she wants to
meet again they don't meet with her
whoo-hoo I would remember that I had
people coming up to me saying all kinds
of things about Hillary and I'm willing
to believe almost anything about it and
I used to get rid of them all the
headlines today CNN always John Don jr.
admits he was looking for dirt on
Hillary from the rock and they weren't
looking for dirt on Donald Trump only
the dossier when I when I ran when I ran
against them they were looking for dirt
on me every day
I mean that's what you do except maybe
you shouldn't but you do it nothing
illegal about that and even if it comes
from her from a Russian or a German or
an American it doesn't matter and they
never used it as the main thing never
used that they rejected it there was
collusion with the Russians they would
have used it do you think that and when
you when you look at all the main flash
points the Trump Tower meeting the
stormy Daniels payment the radon mana
for at the radon Cohen is there any one
part of that that concerns you more than
other parts of that yeah their inability
to reach a conclusion that is obvious
and their unwillingness to recognize the
damage this does to our country all over
the world there's no reason for this
investigation there never was a good
reason for in the first place this was
engineered by Comey with the with the
with the the report not that report that
the interviews thing that he wrote that
he should have never revealed which he
leaked illegally through a professor I
mean nobody DOJ is releasing those
documents by the way that particular on
that particular professor call me should
be under the Dan Richmond and the
Clinton people wanted him fired before
we did for what he did to her that was
totally unethical
yeah but totally unethical to reveal all
the facts incriminating her and then
this specious argument that you
shouldn't be prosecuted do you have any
information or any sense again given
your background at justice how these
things tend to go that there's any
chance that Bob Muller gave immunity to
Jim Comey
no I don't I have no no idea if he gave
him immunity I don't know why he's not
being investigated that troubles us
because a lot of the president's
statements contradict Comey they're much
more logical than commis but they
contradict it if you want to just
believe call me then you're walking him
into a trap and commis not been
investigated so I don't think we would
sit him down for an interview
unless Comey was investigated and
treated in the same way this guy Jay
Goldberg I guess he was some former
little Trump lawyer I've never heard of
him but he was in Goldberg yeah Jake no
Jake I tried cases again okay well he
said I told him that I didn't think that
Giuliani was the right person to select
I saw what they were much better people
that he could use in terms of
negotiating with Muller I guess I beat
him too many times getting a little old
probably are better people the only
thing that I have is the president
trusts me and I trust the president I
have his back in the right way I believe
I would represent any president which
through this kind of torture
this is not right for our country that's
why I'm doing this I'm doing a pro bono
and I'm doing it because I believe that
this is just plain wrong the family that
told the steaks on the Family
you mentioned Ivanka before you said
jared is disposable I'm not sure that
one I was kidding Jared loved it Jared
loved that he said to my wife tell you
to say that and I said no but you are
disposable Jared men all we are
disposable - you're not worried you're
not worried about exposure that he has
because that meeting with a Russian
banker and decided can I figure out why
that meeting means what it means first
of all none of it was about getting her
emails it was about dirty information
they have alleged to have they didn't
have it so distorted I'm talking about
the meeting that Jared had with that
Russian taxi in December of 2016 a
different business thing has nothing to
do with collusion with the Russians over
over the elections over at that point I
think if you ordered a White Russian
that the Russian tearoom wants you
you'd be in trouble here I haven't been
in Russia in four years of five years
thank God do you do you have any concern
that there is no real way at this point
to get a fair outcome by a special
council that many very well-respected
lawyers think was begun named on
spurious fraudulent grounds well I'm
confident that if we have to we can be
at vindicated in court I don't think we
we're going to have to but I think we
get vindicated in court I'm still
hopeful that when it comes down or what
they're not gonna impair their
reputations with a bogus room you're not
going to court with the president though
he's gonna be interviewed she's not
gonna be in court he's gonna he's gonna
be in Congress referred challenging the
legitimacy of their investigatory
authority and the way they've spanned it
out so much you so you you maintain that
the expansion of this probe as it's been
expand and the mystery legitimate what
they did would man afford what they did
with Michael Cohen all the illegitimate
things they've done possibly placing a
spy in the Trump campaign all these
things are areas where indictments have
been dismissed because the government is
conduct some of these same people have
done it I do not understand what bob was
thinking of hiring these people are you
concerned about any of the former Trump
White House staffers I know hope Hicks
her name was thrown around and in
working with Don jr. maybe on the
statement about the Trump Tower meeting
are you worried about her conversations
at all with the special counsel I mean
these guys are young these are young
kids give me one thousand and one
prosecutions yeah does a full statements
right not under oath god that would be
really cheap yeah that'd be like he's
turning the screws on people well it
says judge Ellis said he's turning the
screws on people not because he cares
about mana for 2004-2007 bank banking
issues he cares about getting a trump
out that's what he cares about couldn't
man afford 2004
2005 activity have mana for it's
different from someone I'm not I'm not
saying anyone live just saying man
afford is different from a 30 year old
or a 25 year old who's like I'm not
gonna lose my I'm not gonna lose my
livelihood you know how they operate you
were a prosecutor this is why I work
with for under Enchantix pressure she's
fantastic she's not gonna my no no I'm
just using is it against any staffer you
know you know what they can do you know
how they work you said this here I have
an email if they did that to her then
adjust problem would have to step in and
act because it would be just a total
injustice and they've done a few of
Justices but not quite as bad as that
yet timeline what is your optimal
timeline for this to wrap up they should
do it today I mean as soon as possible
now I think that they have the facts
from which they can write their report
if you're going to write a fair report
fine write it if you're going to write
an unfair report write it and we will
combat it we're ready to rip it apart
and we're ready to rip them apart if
that's what they want
we would rather peacefully settle this
and get it over with
Rudy Guiliani thank you always great to
see you thanks for coming up